♪♪
JANUARY 10, 1992.
A CONTAINER SHIP TRAVELING
FROM HONG KONG
TO TACOMA, WASHINGTON,
LOSES 12 CONTAINERS OVERBOARD.
ONE OF THEM SETS LOOSE
THOUSANDS OF TINY,
YELLOW, PLASTIC DUCKS
ON THE CURRENTS
OF THE NORTH PACIFIC.
Narrator:
THE CURRENTS CARRY THE DUCKS
ALL OVER THE WORLD.
SO, MONTHS LATER,
THEY START WASHING UP
ON THE COAST OF ALASKA,
TURNING THIS TOY SPILL
INTO AN ACCIDENTAL EXPERIMENT.
SO, FROM THE DUCKY STUDY,
YOU GET REAL-TIME DATA
ABOUT THE CURRENTS
IN THE NORTH PACIFIC.
Narrator:
THE ACCIDENTAL DUCK EXPERIMENT
IS STILL PROVIDING INFORMATION
TODAY.
THEY'RE ALMOST INDESTRUCTIBLE.
I MEAN, LITERALLY 20 YEARS
AFTER THEY HIT THE OCEAN,
THEY'RE STILL WASHING UP
ON BEACHES AROUND THE WORLD.